[Music]
welcome to Hannity tonight yet another
busy news night and we are witnessing
history in the making the American
people they cannot will not be stopped
and let's make one thing perfectly clear
numbers they don't lie president Trump's
agenda is an epic success and according
to brand new economic numbers out today
a new report a whopping 266 thousand new
jobs were added in the month of November
now that includes 54,000 jobs in
manufacturing oh those are the jobs
Barack Obama said are never coming back
unemployment right now down again to
3.5% the lowest level since 1969 another
record an average earnings by the way
hourly earnings are up 3.1 percent even
CNBC host the crazy Jim Cramer he said
the media Bob
well they don't want to report this but
these are the best numbers of our lives
Wow
take a listen cable CNN MSM
so you know what's going on here Joe
people don't want to say good things and
this is the best number I've ever seen
in my life
how can it last forever unless it's a
participation rate in it if you know I
think you could it has to go up Joe
because when we win them trade war which
you know we're going to win now because
we have the better numbers then they're
gonna have to put jobs here that's what
they're gonna have to do we're not even
talking about that yet in the end the
Chinese got to put jobs here and you
know something Joe it doesn't I can't it
doesn't matter whether you hate them I
like them these are real numbers you
know what thank God America's economy is
booming like never before but this is
not a worldwide trend not at all in fact
under the far-left leadership of that
2-phase Trudeau our friends to the north
in Canada their economy is declining in
a massive way look at this the month of
November Canada lost seventy-one
thousand jobs the biggest drop since
2009 the unemployment rate there jumped
to nearly 6 percent now Trudeau you
might want to take note President Trump
he lowered taxes in this country got rid
of burdensome regulation fought for
better trade deals
yeah you have to pay more and empowered
America and its energy sector we are now
for the first time in 75 years a net
exporter of energy and by the way now
Canada you're suffering this economy in
America is the envy of the world
by the way if I was a radical socialist
Democrat right now I think I'd be a
little nervous about election 2020 peace
and prosperity Baghdadi's dead best
economy since 1969 employment wise Oh
Trump's policies are working now this is
an agenda that's been an overwhelming
success Democrats have nothing to offer
they have done nothing for three years
except hate Donald Trump and their wild
socialist fantasies ninety four trillion
new Green Deal fifty-two trillion
Medicare for all but no private
insurance nothing but baseless what an
impeachment charade more conspiracy
theories more lies you got three of the
most corrupt dishonest politicians in
the swamp of Washington by the way the
circus
that's what draining the swamp looks
like they don't like being drained and
exposed all the swamp creatures and by
the way the so-called Democratic
frontrunner Wow what a bad week sleepy
creepy crazy Uncle Joe 303 300 trained
rec for the 73 77 year-old candidate
already had a lot of baggage
today he actually suggests that his
campaign could attract younger voters
because he's not as old as Bernie
Sanders as a campaign slogan oh the no
malarkey toward nobody under 90 knows
what malarkey means by the way on the
same day as the monster jobs report well
he predicted a recession can you imagine
you have to actually to get your power
about you have to pray the economy goes
down and Americans get hurt I wouldn't
want to be in that position if I was a
politician you also promised he would
never break a promise really and even
picked a fight with his partners with
his party's moral leader yes socialist
leader squad leader Alexandria Cassio
Cortes take a look
medicare-for-all do you think that's
polar Department was there
parties not there at all
I'm some of your opponents are yeah but
the party's not there you know the
numbers what do you think no guys got it
all wrong about what happened and what
it was from no look you know you know
it's not fake he's just bad judgment you
all thought that what happened was the
party moved extremely to the left after
Hilary AOC was the new party she's a
bright wonderful person but where's the
party come on me now all of those pales
in comparison to what we saw yesterday
Biden had a full-blown
public meltdown why because an 83 year
old Iowa voter dared to ask the obvious
question that the mob and the media
would never ask that would be about the
kwid and the Pro and the quo with Joe
and hunter and burry smih holdings this
is a serious scandal the mob is ignoring
it we tell you the truth it deserves
answers we deserve answers he leveraged
a billion of our dollars 1 billion you
not getting the billion unless you fire
the prosecutor investigating my zero
experience son if you fire him you get
the billion you got 6 hours son of a B
they fired him but instead Joe 303
Trillo actually called out the voter
what did he call him fat and stupid and
old and he said hey man hey Jack one of
a push-up contest take a look
you know I know you do by the way that's
why I'm not sedentary I don't I get up
and look the reason I'm running is
because I've been around a long time and
I know more than most people know
can I get things done that's why I'm
running and you want to check my shape
on let's do push-ups together man what's
good what's wrong let's do whatever you
want to do no one has said my son has
done anything wrong and I did not any
occasion and nothing has ever said you
said I setup my son to work on an oil
company they know what you said I got
your word straight Jack you do there's a
deal
all right Jose clearly agitated because
he has a lot to hide and while the mob
and the media they're more than willing
to give him a free pass voters won't
offer Joe the same courtesy American
people get it can't fool the American
people
although the voter you just saw was
angrily confronted look at this this is
after the Town Hall by a Biden supporter
watch this why don't you just get out of
here
[Music]
these Biden people are really angry they
may need anger management classes you
know what it is
to swamp the sewer the mob they hate to
be challenged this is not going away I
won't let it go away and by the way it's
big if Joe Biden wins his party
nomination you know I don't know why
because his real Ukrainian quid and pro
and quo will be a major topic every
single day and in a candid moment even
Mike Bloomberg admitted President Trump
will destroy Biden and every other
Democrat in the upcoming election let's
see what the nanny state mayor has to
say I watched and I said we just can't
have another four years of this and then
I watched all the candidates and I just
thought to myself Donald Trump would eat
him up you think all the candidates who
were running today he would eat them up
let me rephrase it I think that I would
do the best job of competing with him
and beating him no you said he'd eat him
up he'll eat you up - I tell you I think
I'm just guessing so let's recap 2020
Democrats they're weak they're angry
they're unhinged and the Trump economy
is soaring oh and by the way the Isis
Caliphate in Syria has been defeated and
Baghdady and company are dead and the
three-ring circus is impeachment coup
attempt well on Capitol Hill that's been
a total unmitigated disaster and
breaking tonight the Trump
administration they just announced
they're not going to participate in
these sham proceedings on Wednesday
during his very first hearing Judiciary
cherri chairman the nutty Nadler he
couldn't even stay awake look at this he
can't stay awake he has all of these you
know ivory tower professors lecturing
Americans we the smelly Walmart shoppers
irredeemable deplorable
those of us to believe in God above and
we cling to our God and our Bibles and
our religion and our Second Amendment
guilty as charged smelly wall more voter
included he couldn't stay awake as his
old witnesses droned on and on about the
virtues of impeachment led by the guy
that thought Trump should be impeached
because he tweeted out the words fake
and news which is totally true
it's okay by the way nutty Nadler I'm
sure you weren't the only ones sleeping
now on Thursday after only one hearing
now remember we had the shift show it
was a shift show when that happened we
had OH all these witnesses not one of
them oh wait a minute
only one they were either hearsay
witnesses or opinion witnesses now we
had three of these ivory tower
professors they witnessed nothing the
only one witness we have in this is a
guy by the name of ambassador Sandlin I
asked the president well what do you
want to release the money nothing no
quid pro or quo like Joe and speaker
Pelosi knows it's a disaster after the
three disastrous
well academics let's just end it here
let's go full speed ahead with
impeachment okay
on what evidence this is the same Pelosi
who railed against the impeachment
proceedings in the 90s in fact she
accused Republicans of impeaching Bill
Clinton merely because they hated him
well Ken Starr did identify eleven
specific felonies and Clinton didn't
lose his law license and he paid
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
Paula Jones but that was then of course
now full hypocrisy on display take a
look for yourself
and as a Catholic I resent your using
work paid in a sentence that addresses
me we are here today because the
Republicans in the House are paralyzed
with hatred of President Clinton and
until the Republicans free themselves of
this hatred our country will suffer Oh
country suffering now there's nothing
here the level of hypocrisy is
breathtaking totally unbelievable I you
have to bifurcate your brain you care
about Russian interference oh you don't
care about the dirty dossier you care
about obstruction but not the subpoenaed
emails leech bit hammers oh you care
about me too and I believe but you don't
say a word about the lieutenant governor
and the Commonwealth of Virginia really
what a bunch of hypocrites
what about Ukrainian election
interference sure Russia interfered
guilty
Devon Nunez told us what happened 2014
it happened well you're now watching it
encapsulates today's modern radical
extreme Democratic Party and of course
yes their official press office known as
the media mob state-run TV they're so
corrupted by their anti Trump rage and
hate it's a psychosis
nothing else matters truth logic reason
common sense even an improving economy
helping the lives of the American people
none of that matters to them and it
happened in spite of them because they
offered no help instead their focus like
a laser beam on one thing one thing only
destroy Trump get their power back